citizens of the reject Nation we've been
waiting all day to hear Lulu Clemens
talk about She-Hulk episode 8 the
Daredevil episode the one we've been all
waiting for the Easter eggs and
breakdown John how are you I'm excited
how are you sir I'm feeling better about
the Daredevil beanie because so many of
you guys have reached out to me we have
started GoFundMe
I've already raised ten thousand dollars
toward your next 20 beanie I might be
able to find everyone who reached out
about like you find it yet I haven't I
called a restaurant I called a movie
theater the only two places I'm like
since the last Daredevil episode the
only two places I've been no siding of
it still can't find it but thank you
guys for reaching out leave a like thank
you and uh let's see what's going on
it's a thick one thick one thick boy
welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clements here to break down
episode eight
eight yeah this is got it so I'm here to
break down episode eight of She-Hulk for
you which was both great and amazing and
sexually liberating but also bad
horrible and once I get my hands on the
Intelligentsia I swear to God I'm gonna
wind up and punch him right in the
goddamn throat
Daredevil and LeapFrog and get to learn
a lot of new things since we've last
seen Matt also this mat is super funny
acrobatic and overall just really fun
it's really crazy so let's just get into
it because I'm sure you want to hear
about Daredevil as much as Mt wants to
hang out with LeapFrog really quick I've
seen some people who I I kind of
expected it and I think a lot of us did
that people might be like Jarred or be
like they ruin Daredevil look if they're
making them funny I actually think it
lines up well with where Daredevil
season three particularly ended and also
and I've actually read some Daredevil
comics and his humor is not off base
here yeah it's not like they made him
like a jokester or a quipper like they
did a really nice job of keeping it in
character which sometimes they don't but
here I think they absolutely did we
opened this episode to Jen and smart
Hulk from episode 1 discussing how Jen
is going to make She-Hulk work and yes
it's w-o-r-k but also
w-e-r-k you get it this is the first
time in an episode started like this
with the music before the previously on
card it's playing the song Work by
rapper musician and nerd Jalissa Wilson
we see Monahans wholesale which we've
seen briefly in the trailers and also an
homage to She-Hulk supervising our
director Drew Monahan we see two robbers
stealing us that's really cool five inch
smart TVs one is played by Anthony
Goolsby and the other is played by
Charles Barden who did stunts for a ton
of other Marvel properties so it makes
sense because he's about to just get
shoulder checked into this van by
LeapFrog right now that's actually a
really good fun fact for you all is that
sometimes the the most reoccurring
cameos you'll see are actually the
stuntmen in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they are constantly being
repurposed for different roles
I guess that makes a lot of sense yeah
just try to think of something to say
off that it's just a fun fact I just
wanted to be a part of that maybe you
try to contribute it's okay I
contributed you did you did a great job
I love your content changes so we're
finally introduced to LeapFrog well you
know like verbally because we've already
seen him before uh Luke Jacobson Studio
but now we're like
Jacob's card frog which I think is a
playoff of like guard dog I don't know I
know you probably heard me boss or Mt
talk about LeapFrog before but for a
quick summary in the comics LeapFrog was
actually Vincent patilio the inventor in
Eugene's father he was a pretty bad guy
but once his father went to the prison
Eugene Don the LeapFrog costume and
swore to use it for good Vince
was known for going head to head with
Daredevil Iron Man The Defenders so it's
not too far off from what we see now
with Daredevil just now entering Eugene
the sun once Dawn in the costume was
known as Prague man who helped
Spider-Man the Human Torch in The
Avengers that doesn't mean he was an
amazing superhero though that does not
mean that he was good at his job at all
don't get into it Twisted he was still
pretty kooky and Goofy that's why he's
involved in She-Hulk they should do like
a Suicide Squad but with some of these
more you know exceptionally effortless
characters like everyone we saw in that
group therapy with uh Abomination he had
Ralph boner in there yeah the frog in
there get Trevor Slattery back again
yeah I want to see that canceled Disney
plushie not ordered to series Disney
plush this family wasn't as wealthy in
the comics but in the She-Hulk series
they certainly are Jen is interviewing
Eugene patilio and her office at GLK and
H and reading a comic book I think that
has LeapFrog on the cover also Jensen
and the comics frog I wonder if she got
it from that guy down the hall electric
coiled Springs in their boots giving
them the ability to jump super far and
high not these rocket shoes but my boy
Tom Michaelson caught this one when the
rocket shoe starts sputtering it's the
same sound of the Millennium Falcon
hyperdrive
team
hey
this is crazy that's cool for
post-production sound Services you Star
Wars nerd you oh that's really cool
that's a funny story title and I guess
leapfrog's catchphrase which is time to
rip it and rip it which just reminds me
of Beyblades and I really like it once
Jennifer another client is suing Luke
Jacobson she runs straight to Holden
hallway's office who says he doesn't
want to upset Mr patillo senior so we've
got leapfrog's dad now in the company
Todd's also a client so it's not adding
up the way I want it's all a little too
suspicious the very beginning I pitched
Holden Holloway was in on it all and it
looks like unlikely but it also isn't it
could still be happening also I
theorized many times we've probably
already seen leapfrog's dad in episode
4. the merry guy that hits on Jen and
Nikki who I know from Eugene and his
father are seemingly rich rich enough to
give his son a secret lair out of their
building or it could be a front for used
cars but still they're building either
way so it's good to note the sus
Behavior because it's very susque it's
like a weed farm Jacobson Studio he's
working on Jen's gala dress and Luke is
not having these false allegations he
rips Jen's outfit off of the mannequin
and he's completely done with her we're
back with judge price who we last saw
him in episode one and three and in
Swagger's our good old friend Charlie
Cox AKA Matt Murdoch AKA Daredevil now
let me remind you the last time we saw a
daredevil Matt was mourning the laws of
Elektra after the Defenders while foggy
and Karen mourn his death death we get a
lot of Senseless murdered by Dex AKA
Bullseye we find Matt's mom bring
Vanessa back in the end we get an epic
showdown between Dex Matt and Wilson
Fisk Dex buying gets crumbled this goes
back to prison foggy Karen and Matt
reunite happily everything's blue skies
exactly then we see decks being worked
on by Kenji oyama and the rest is
history and as a reminder Charlie Cox
said in an interview that Daredevil born
again is like a season one not a season
four it's a whole new thing so some
things may spill over but ultimately I
think it's okay to assume not all of
season three will come to the MCU this
is also just an FYI for how we last saw
him in the bigger scope of things not
with his like Cameo that he made in
Spider-Man no way home and this
Daredevils got jokes he saw jokes in the
Netflix series this one's pure comedy
yeah I know I noticed they kept it kind
of vague when he was talking about his
Law Firm back home he wasn't really
specifying you know exactly like what
it's called who's there he doesn't name
drop foggy or Karen or anything of that
sort so I feel like they left the door
open to have some wiggle room of what
they really want to keep and what they
really want to bring back I feel like
they got to bring it I feel like it has
to be a season one and a season four at
the same time I feel like you should at
least bring back the core three because
they have such a great chemistry already
and I feel like having him be the same
but having them to be different after
already making such a big impression
would kind of be weird yeah you know
like I feel like it would be a lot to
swallow because everybody does have such
an association at the same time I dude
think that yeah he was funnier here but
I feel like I'm born again he's I think
he's gonna get really serious mark my
words or else I'm gonna clip this moment
out when we're reacting to that show
this scene also mirrors our free comics
QR code and she holds number four by
Charles She-Hulk is friends with Matt so
much so she goes for him for advice they
let her go head to head Jen defending
and Matt Prosecuting Steve Rogers this
is one of my favorite runs they were
both chosen just because they're
phenomenal lawyers now Jen breaks the
fourth wall calling Matt an [ __ ] for
asking for the motion to compel
production of The defendant's Client
List be rejected as it's not relevant to
the litigation which is complete lawyer
jargon Mumbo jump talk for first things
first Jacobson is not giving you his
Client List because it has nothing to do
with the case now this is when they
begin using a lot of lawyer jargon and
I'll be breaking it down like really
quickly for you because I watch enough
Law and Order she holds says we need the
list because there's probably other
people who have been affected just like
this Matt says Luke's record for working
with people is top tier there should be
no complaints She-Hulk summarizes more
reason to bring clients to the stand if
he has nothing to hide then there's no
worries right Matt basically argues an
invasion of privacy on the client's end
where Jen remarks this basically isn't a
private issue people should know what
they're getting into by hiring Luke
first where Matt returns right that's
right
Heroes which need to remain anonymous at
times and brings up the sokovia Accords
being repealed as an example okay so
this itself is already pretty big news
and to some small news to others but to
me I think it's a pretty big deal as a
reminder the sokovia Accords were
introduced in Civil War the whole
framework is to regulate the activities
of superheroes more so enhanced
individuals when our superheroes even
fought against it remember they were
sent to the rap so this is not just a
little little slap on the wrist this is
a big deal the Accords were seemingly
still in place even after the blip and
even during one division so now that we
know they've been repealed in 2025
because that's seemingly when she Oak
takes place that means enhanced
individuals can basically do whatever
they want not necessarily like oh yeah
that's true another Lagos incident or
just not having the closer monitor on
how these folks are engaging and saving
the day I mean does that sound dangerous
to you let me know how you feel because
I genuinely was team Captain America so
I was against the Accords but still what
happens when a bunch of innocent people
get hurt in the crossfire it just seems
like ooh a recipe for a lot of disaster
it's actually a really good point that's
a very solid point a lot of people
talked about that when that was dropped
but I didn't take the time to read too
much into it only because it was just
kind of like a just kind of like threw
it away that line ever since the Cobia
cores were repealed I guess I would have
treated like a bigger deal if there was
like an episode or a movie that's since
there was one movie that completely
revolved around it thought it might have
been like oh maybe it was something that
I just sort of missed over the times of
all these Marvel movies yeah because it
seems like something else would have to
go in its place for how much of a big
deal it was putting them into place to
begin with me here just my wishful
thinking part of me goes well maybe we
could kind of explore that energy Hulk
season two and maybe actually get some
litigation going but also have something
that's like law oriented that has really
going to affect the whole MCU maybe
that's the whole thing of kamala's law
that quite keeps bringing up that's
right this is on the argument and trial
becomes more about Daredevil and
She-Hulk than opposed to Luke Jacobson
and LeapFrog they're arguing about being
anonymous to being well known while they
both kind of take Jabs at one another
it's clear their personal lives are
rolling over into this case also it's so
on the nose but I love this line he's
lying don't ask me how I know I just
know yes Mr Burdock we all know how
Daredevil knows Eugene is lying he can
smell the fumes and also hear the
heartbeat he is not a bat but close
enough and unfortunately Jen technically
loses her second case if you want to
count the Titania storming in and
disrupting as a loss and technically
getting Donnie to sign the cease and
desist later to it so yeah maybe two
they fixed that wall really fast it's
delivered a green Appletini from Matt
and I do declare this man is giving me
the vapors
so funny I'm green I get it
he even later hints at his new suit made
by Luke Jacobs that we can only assume
is the new Daredevil threads by Luke
Jacobson
and Murdoch his Law Firm back in Hell's
Kitchen possibly cold Nelson Murdock and
Paige now right because that's how we
ended season three hopefully they bring
that over or it just feels like kind of
messed up to be like Karen still works
for us but her name is taken off the
headlines
can use them all to help people when
Society fails
and she all can help people when the law
fails him it reminds me of in the comics
when Matt and Jen had a heart to heart
on how being an attorney can't go the
same lengths as being a superhero he
used this to break Felicia Hardy AKA
black cat out of prison when it was
proven she was framed and oh boy Jen are
we ever feeling this guy also I know
right he stepped away for that phone
call it must have been for Luke and he's
handling it so calmly as Daredevil does
time and time again that's when the
worst thing that could ever happen
happens Todd asked Jen for legal advice
and they need to talk ASAP immediately
and he's being a dick about it we're
meeting Todd at hoof and flower on
Wilshire Wilshire is long but it's in
West Hollywood near Beverly Hills am I
correct
Todd is demanding to meet there Todd is
waiting sipping on some rest I hate I
hate that Boulevard
behind him he's clearly not here to talk
about law this is around Sean Park he
yells at a quiet restaurant wakanda
forever and puts his arms to his chest
yeah made me completely uncomfortable he
also purchased an authentic wakanda War
spear at an auction which we can assume
is probably one to the door melange now
this part where Todd says they want it
back because colonizers took it from
them is a big deal and important to note
in the first Black Panther movie we
first see adult killmonger at the Museum
of Great Britain looking over the
wakanan artifact that's actually
vibranium this item was taken by British
soldiers in Benin but we know back in
the day a lot of Western Nations during
the war and colonization stole so many
African art pieces and rightfully
African countries deserve their
artifacts but people like Todd who
clearly love Africa want to keep it he
thinks he deserves it for dropping a
million on it and taking a clearly
photoshopped photo with the damn spear
like a damn colonizer so if people are
suspecting black panther wakanda forever
to possibly take place in 2023 or 2024.
She-Hulk is allegedly 2025. I think the
connection is that after whatever
happens in wakanda Forever there's
another step for wakanda moving forward
when I say this I mean in the first
black panther claw was clearly a threat
but everyone was mixed on whether
t'challa should stay or leave they
weren't as worried about the artifact
and in the end they started expanding
their Outreach now and wakanda forever
trailer we get the sweet line that I
love so much where she says we know what
you whisper they have lost their
protector now it's our time to strike
that clearly can be aimed towards a lot
of things but I think and play with it
is the idea that it didn't make us
weaker and made us stronger we as a
nation and when I say we and as I'm
talking about wakanda I'm sorry I I just
feel like I'm from there and they'll be
doubling down on everything getting back
in order and moving forward like never
before and one of those steps could be
reclaiming their stolen goods maybe
we'll see some of that at the end of
wakanda forever I would love it if the
writers are watching your breakdown and
are like
yep yeah we totally thought of all that
yep that's exactly what we were it's uh
we got one more set of reshoots right I
feel like the sokovia chords reveal line
was something that feige was like you
got to write this in here that like what
was it so instead of the sokovia course
appeal you're setting up the Daredevil
show and you're setting up some stuff
from Black Panther yeah people are
worried the phase four isn't
interconnected enough so this episode
has to get to three movies at least
episode eight changed it all can we put
Todd in wakanda Forever can we do that
and also the it was cut out of our
reaction because I was trying to like
make sure the best parts were kept for
time to get you all the Daredevil
goodies and keep you watching they
reveal his last name is Phillips have we
talked about in our discussion his last
name is Phillips it's Todd Phillips Todd
Phillips we live in a society is this a
crack at Todd Phillips yeah because he's
not created as Todd Phillips and the
credits for some reason but his name's
Todd Phillips
director of The Hangover
waiting for him to clap back on Twitter
we also learned in the scene that Todd
studied abroad in wakanda this could be
why Ruby Williams is in wakanda in the
first place she could be studying abroad
also in the comics Brody from Miss
Marvel left to study abroad in wakanda
this will probably be Tethered to their
Outreach and helping those outside of
wakanda we see Jen's suit which has been
many upon many upon many variations of
in the comics but I like this one the
most because it feels more practical you
know if I had to look great from the
comics you know it'll be flimsy all my
bits and chips will be all over the
place so yes we like practicality in
women's fighting fits it's what we want
of course Jen's strong enough to stop a
car with her calf she basically shoulder
checked them in the comics and also no
Daredevil's acrobatic nature we don't
see much of this in the Netflix series
but he was always very accuratic in the
comments now I know we've been waiting
for this for a long time and we all know
about his suit change but you know it's
a breakdown so I have to talk about it
so Daredevil is now wearing a red and
yellow suit instead of his normal red
and black we've seen before now it
doesn't stray too far from the comic's
depiction but also good to note that
this is a Luke Jacobson original no not
Melvin Potter also Daredevil really said
my ass remains unwoofed I just love how
funny he is also yes he was still very
funny has sense of humor in the
Daredevil series when he wasn't so
brooding but here he's not that brooding
after fighting in the parking lot which
I refer to as the dance of the soups
another thing that we can point out is
that he's in the heart of Hell's Kitchen
he's taking a break from Hell's Kitchen
he got his suit from Luke Jacobson and
not the very dark depressed neurotic
Melton not at the dingy like Chop Shop
he makes that stuff in yeah all the
worst crimes in the MCU happen in New
York City this is like a vacation trip
truly truly truly it's like any show
that randomly does an LA episode
everything's lighter and everyone's on
speed a little bit yeah we see him
poster for Rogers the musical and
Despierta news which we've seen on a
couple other episodes and a giant poster
for Donnie Blaze if you remember him
that son of a [ __ ] again not Jen's
first time lifting a car you guys we saw
do it in that credit scene that one
episode also this is happening and
LeapFrog is speeding past Avis on Flower
Street in downtown Los Angeles once Jen
finds out Daredevil is actually a Matt
she questions his power like
echolocation which we know is like he
has radar sense but it's maybe it's just
easier to be like yeah I'm like a bat
it's echo location yeah morbius I think
another very unrealistic touch about
this show is they would have definitely
been chased by the cops oh sure there
would be cops somewhere downtown L.A
full of police everywhere God they just
Patrol that amount of speedium like
there's no way and all that damage
happening in this park no way I'm like
if you drive to downtown L.A at this
time of night there will be more cop
cars than regular cars around also Jen
says this I assume the guy dressed as
the devil was the bad one which could
also be a nod to Bullseye from Daredevil
season 3 who is the bad guy dressed up
like a devil running around town also it
plays Daredevil's sick intro and I'm
stoked we're all stoked devil
I'm Daredevil they clear Star Wars
so excited for and in super bogus news
Jed has never heard of Daredevil before
maybe because his heroic Feats don't
reach the West Coast or maybe because
they're so small in Hell's Kitchen it's
nothing to California there's also been
a lot of stuff happening in between
these two shows so it's not surprising
that Jen doesn't know who he is and
maybe that'll give way to the future of
the MCU when he shows up they take Jen's
Prius this last episode to the lily pad
which is his secret lair Eugene
batillios and you can tell by their
family's name on the side of the
building and peep that we buy houses QR
code that leads you to the Charles sule
run of She-Hulk 2014 issue number nine I
talked about earlier my favorite issue
from surely we
I gotta do that every time now I hate to
be this person but LeapFrog secret lair
is sick as hell the old school LeapFrog
art on the wall oh no way you're a
completely green secret Labs gamer chair
the yellow diving helmet which I don't
know yes characters that wear the yellow
diving helmet other than Mysterio thank
you Brandon but I do know this is a
swampy inspired Lair so maybe they
pulled inspiration from Scooby-Doo we
have the brass frog lamp frog parking
only LeapFrog Beacon Light like Batman's
little signals little blue frog game on
the table a green motorcycle Frogger and
leap Frogger at first I thought the
Frogger sign was just posted over
another game but it actually just
genuinely looks like that a greenish
trampoline clearly a lily pad and a
little child park riding frog this man
if it's green or if it's a frog put it
in my Lair unappreciated production
design I'm kidding that blue Jacobson
for a minute I didn't believe I was like
maybe it was a mistake maybe it was the
dad but no he he stole a man he stole
Luke Jacobson he tells Luke and wants
his new suit to have bulletproof Shields
a fancy AI with a British voice most
likely a nod to Iron Man and Jarvis also
peep this lamp with all the old school
LeapFrog stickers it's just like swagged
out Daredevil brings up the difference
between henchmen and goons that I love
and never noticed that henchmen believe
in the cause goons are just there for
the paycheck and that's great to keep in
mind also okay
devil listens to Jen's a heartbeat nah
like come on
I wish I could do that you're right
long hallway again don't we just love
these scenes where he's always fighting
people in hallways and the lights are
just contrasting everything I just love
it Philly clubs extend and have the
special steel fiber cable that allows it
to shoot out you're seeing during the
fight we see this also I think in season
two the walkie-talkie before we start
going crazy about what Cobra is Cobra
because this is the first time we see it
in this episode trust me we also see it
on LeapFrog seat belts but I think it's
because his car is modeled after the
1960 Shelby Cobra also cobridge is the
brand of walkie-talkies so don't don't
read too much into it unless he's just a
fan of that brand challenge
we've got a crossbow guy a crowbar guy a
sort of grappling hook on a chain guy
you know those kinds of people are wild
this squad of tadpoles is Messy as The
Wrecking Crew and very misplaced they
don't know their weapons they just don't
even know what they're doing we're ready
for this Throwdown another hallway fight
everything we wanted this blue light
casted upon us we are so cool
falls through the ceiling smashing the
goons with debris with our very own new
She-Hulk catchphrase I guess She-Hulk
smash
and yes Jen he's doing it for all of us
he's doing it for you he's doing it for
me we're all into this we all want to
have sex with him too
funny screw that so funny true saying
what we're all thinking Jen definitely
kill those people she definitely I was
just thinking that again She-Hulk smash
skulls and and rib cages and all sorts
of other things I know and they usually
do like random asides to be like no no
they're knocked out or whatever but yeah
in this case that would definitely
murder regular human beings which she
did oh sure well I mean you know they
all got blood clots to say the least
they are all walking away yeah with
irreparable damage for sure and I mean
you know not the Daredevil smashed
anybody with debris but like you know he
kicked that guy and then he like fell
and hit his face onto a tape like that
guy's probably paralyzed if nothing more
that son and just like his father in the
comics LeapFrog jumps out the window
breaking his legs now this is maybe the
funniest and most embarrassing thing
I've ever seen done in a comic and if
you've seen worse please at me try to
because
LeapFrog jumping out of a window and
breaking his legs in the comics is very
funny
oh
we weren't reading too much into it not
me screaming at Daredevils clothes lying
in the ground like those little kids
dropping the breadcrumbs I a God good
Lord Cody I do love how his clothes were
neatly placed there too yeah in a
perfect Triumph before I meet you on the
bed I need to fold my clothes okay can I
put them down gently I just got these
from Luke Jacobson you done read us an
episode and I love it baby thank you
Cody thank you so much the next morning
the morning after the Walk of Shame
baloney Daredevil's never been prouder
also I'm sure we'll see Daredevil again
because we have one more episode and
Titania posted this today which is
Charlie Cox in the same room we saw at
blonsky's retreat no way
yes
Obama stay someone said that he wasn't
doing the walk of shame that he had his
shoes off because it was just helping
him walk
because he's blind and sensing but I was
like but he's normally walking with his
almost always he would need to be if
that's the justification he would need
this would have been part of the
character
now on a different network entirely on
the one or maybe two off Cameo I thought
it was like he's walking with his feet
in the grass like ooh I'm happy that's I
think more likely just yeah it's the
morning I want to catch the Dew like us
Jen breaks the fourth wall saying it
feels like the episode should be over
and it's not over I I feel the same way
I I was like we're all at this point
right and I think this is also really
important to know that she's never broke
the fourth wall this much being so aware
that the episode should in fact be over
Jen reminds us and is very surprised
that the next episode is actually the
finale which
just getting getting all my kisses out
before it actually happens and a very
brighter knowing situation right before
the finale usually comes the climax or
the twist and even Jen says it so we're
expecting the next five to ten minutes
to be probably horrific and they are
either way before we get to that part
they are teasing us about this red hole
she even mentions Red Hulk and we've all
been thinking about it we all been
expecting Todd to be red Hulk so if you
don't know Red Hulk was Thunderbolt Ross
in the comic books the Intelligentsia
gave Thunderbolt Ross the ability to
transform into the Red Hulk to better
fight the Hulk now and the comics we
really didn't know who Red Hulk was for
a while but we do know Abomination
killed Betty Ross with Thunderbolt Ross
freed him to kill Hulk and Thunderbolt
raw spirals but all that happened
offered to basically bring back his
daughter and also kill Hulk for good so
they injected Ross with gamma radiation
which turned him into the Red Hulk and
the leader when bringing Betty Ross back
to life turned her into the Red She-Hulk
I would love to see this play out
clearly in the She-Hulk series people
are expecting it to be Todd which I am
still banking on I will put money down
on top odd turning into Red Hulk by the
end of the series hopefully that sounds
annoying Jen also mentions am I getting
fridged which is a term meaning to kill
hurt assault basically de-power women in
stories to boost
you've definitely seen done shoot that
happens to Gwen Stacy all the time you
guys the term was coined by you've never
heard that one and ultimately refers to
the Green Lantern issue number 53 where
he comes home to his apartment and finds
his girlfriend dead and stuffed in their
fridge these storylines I didn't see in
situations where like the women didn't
really need to die you know Green
Lantern didn't need to overcome anything
because his girlfriend's death he would
have solved it on his own and what I'm
saying is this is just mainly in writing
it's not Green Lantern's fault it's in
the writing's fault so Gail created a
website showing every time women in
comics were used solely to push male
story arc wow that's their own damn
problems we're not a throwaway device
you guys you can't just use this for
your storylines the further them in this
way round out your characters don't use
us dying or being assaulted as your
ticket out my dude it's not that hard
yeah if you're a good writer you can
write that was my that's my rant about
being fridge because it's a it happens
still happens it happens in every show
okay hear me out
new rockstars kills off Jess Clemens
uh-huh to help motivate and get more
people to watch the channel when Mt and
Eric Foster doing breakdowns yeah
everybody has to band together that way
there's more of an emotional core and
you watch those guys grow over time yeah
as they grieve through the process like
oh can you rock stars still continue
with the loss of Jess and then
ultimately yeah like makes everybody
grow that much more you know like you
are the the thing that everyone thinks
about now in memoriam as these two men
soar to greater and greater Heights and
you will have made the men better in the
long run and it's all thanks to you
thanks to you woman while they reap the
benefits yeah
no that's actually a really
fascinating terminology I've never heard
that before have you heard that phrase
I've never heard that phrase once or
twice but not enough that it's the first
Association but now it will be yeah I'm
like oh there's a whole like
deconstruction of this thing that I had
never never heard of before part of the
Trope about that doing it to women but
I've never heard the term fridging never
heard that before just before we
transitioned Nikki is about to do Jen's
makeup and come on come on that's not
the Wolverine not I'm not having it
we've got three if we want to count the
sneakers we've had three Wolverine nods
and now that we know that Wolverines
coming into Deadpool three how are you
not gonna stop acknowledging it if
you're not gonna acknowledge it you know
I'm just I just I love uh whatever we're
at the Southern California law Awards
which we've seen earlier in the trailer
Jen steps out looking beautiful in the
silver dress and heals the match the
song playing is the next big thing by
West Rose we see Jen's parents Elaine
and Morris Walter Holden is there and
Peep Todd's hair okay just remember that
hair remember the back of that hair
because we're gonna come back oh is he
in The Mask or something being a Luke
Jacobson Zoo Rod collaboration and I'm
sorry if I butchered your name but this
is a real Lebanese fashion designer not
fictional real person we're table 14 and
pug is also there Jen wins
we all thought it was gonna be just one
winner and it's five Karen Hunter Alice
Chen Joanne Torres Barbara Wells and our
good suspicious friend Mallory book I
don't know if they did this on purpose
but each of those people other than
Mallory book are actual attorneys in
California Jen is really cool no way
well done and it's like Pepe frog like I
just I hate this and a distorted voice
breaking through blaring do you want to
see who She-Hulk really is the
intelligency is giving a speech about
hating She-Hulk like every Ransom video
I've ever seen made now I hate to do
this but it's my breakdown so we gotta
talk about it they pull up Jen's natural
likes or text messages photos of Captain
America during Civil War her bills and
including this video of her and Josh
sleeping together where Josh actually
recorded this horrible like revenge porn
and now it's being played for everyone
at this gala this is genuinely the most
horrible and completely messed up thing
I've ever seen in the world like it's it
it's awful it's awful adding people with
like nudes or anything like that in
general but like actually seeing it done
to Jen at this Gala and in front of her
peers clearly she deserves to be a whole
so I'm really sorry it affected you and
I wish I could have tweeted out a
warning but the way I watched this
episode is so sporadic that I it hit me
at two in the morning Jen's reaction is
completely valid though and Mallory
tries to stop her and once Jen breaks
the TV the red alarms go off and we can
assume she'll look like the terror
tonight after the destruction she just
made sort of how Bruce warned her in the
first episode it's like the scene from
Carrie the lights are that's what I said
because these are wide and rude by shy
girl plays and it's literally like the
Eerie Screech noise at the beginning
where Carrie's like they're all gonna
cover you it's horrible there's a chance
that this guy isn't him I I don't think
this could be Todd it might not be I
mean look at The Sideburns look at the
long hair kinda resembles Chad which I
really don't know what no no I'm banking
for Todd I just wanted to be Todd
because he's already an asshat might as
well just make him more of an ass hat
it's kind of crazy how they had
Daredevil come in here who was a very
dark brooding character that people were
kind of like oh they're gonna make him
too funny or something like that
especially put him in the She-Hulk show
and then after he leaves the darkest
moment of the show is actually given to
She-Hulk yeah it's very very strange
yeah and I mean and it's strange but
just
interesting point yeah well and and two
I mean it is
thinking about the mcu's like she said
like this could be triggering to some
people and I was like yeah it really
could be and I can't remember the last
time I felt that way during a Marvel
anything so like it really does kind of
step aside and go no this is something
like real and uncomfortable no matter
how Fantastical the person experiencing
it is
when Stormbreaker was getting jealous a
millionaire
that's not what you're right that's very
triggering because
my inanimate objects that I married
cheated on me
with koi genre wow and we had to talk it
out and it was
it was very triggering when um when
stuff like that happens you know so
that's why he wasn't in our non-spoiler
review for Thor 11 Thunder yeah no he
shouldn't be and you are so brave for
still continuing to work with koi
despite that
well I care more about views oh sure
then those damn two
broomsticks that I married uh-huh if I'm
being really honest
when you were saying that you haven't
seen A Moment Like This so traumatizing
or triggering I was racking my brain for
what moment can I pull from to make a
joke and I probably pulled the worst
thing and it led to a really flat
improfit it led to the best part of
you're going to see the reap most
replayed part of the video is just this
banter right here we get the law coming
in which we can assume to be the dodc
because they're jackets and they're
using the Hulk miniature versions of the
Hulk frequency machine we saw an
Incredible Hulk it feels like that but
it also feels like the machines that
they use and Miss Marvel new courtroom
LeapFrog in the suit bidding on the
wakanan spear what we can assume is
Daredevil and Jen under the covers and
Jen's knocked over J mug and Daredevil's
glove and suit lying on the nightstand
with Jen's bra on top of the helmet
Daredevil passing Nikki on the not so
walk of shame that's everything I've
spotted in the eighth episode of
She-Hulk you guys this episode was
really great I'm so glad that we finally
got Daredevil and with so much great
news of course had to come horrible news
but I know that we'll get them in the
last episode we'll get them in the last
episode follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemens
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns to
everything you love thanks for watching
time to rip it and rip it she-hulk's
gonna kill gonna go on a killing spree
she's gonna murder everyone murder
everyone just like Carrie get an
emergency
Hulk uh guys I hope we get more
Daredevil next week I do too leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
Bell leave a like and hey let's send
this to the patreon
James Smith you're the new Devil of the
reject kitchen you know why I chose you
because your name is spelled cool it's
got a y in the middle and y's got like
two little devil horns so you are our
devil today I want to see I hope you
know I mean this is you're you're more
of a fresh face in our shout out Circle
so you know as we get to know you I'd
like you to send us consensually some
pics maybe of you and some spandex you
know let's let's see what kind of uh you
know physique you're rocking because uh
you know if you're gonna you know be
flipping around and kicking ass in our
name you know to protect the reject
Nation you know you gotta have that
bubble butt you know what I'm saying so
uh Hey keep on keeping on and uh you
know hope you're doing well and thanks
for your support in all seriousness
because that means a lot to have you
here with us and I hope we have not
completely or I have not completely off
put you with this Whimsical shout out
peace brother it's okay if you don't
pledgeable
[Music]